[Musique]
nous avons décidé de montrer notre
touloulou à la martinique à la
guadeloupe en métropole partout on
voudra aller y aller on va décider d'y
aller on ira partout parce que c'est
notre patrimoine et on a envie de le
faire connaître
parce que nos toulouse nous sommes en
train d'essayer de l'inscrire au
patrimoine culturel immatériel de
l'unesco
donc il faut qu'ils soient connus de
tous il faut que tous les amis du monde
entier sache que ce touloulou existe et
qu'il est le nôtre en guyane
[Musique]
m
bon
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
kucka belt
ainsi les guerres alors qui nous lie à
bienne
[Musique]
les protos pour nous c'est que les
martiniquais et le bois de pin viennent
au carnaval de guyane pour la ligue
droite et les hommes et les femmes 1 et
nous voulions que ce carnaval reste
qu'en aval identique c'est-à-dire que
quand les amis viennent en guyane c'est
qu'ils doivent respecter les codes qui
sont instaurées au niveau du tout nous
du bal paré-masqué le premier code c'est
l'anonymat
quand on voit un touloulou qui n'a pas
de cagoule ou qui n'a pas de gants c'est
pas possible
donc c'est l'anonymat anthony loup n'a
pas le droit de partir avec un cavalier
non plus lc 1 décote qui dit que le la
salle de bal paré-masqué c'est pas
un bordel on vient pas chercher femme-là
envié dans des ambiances à musique
donc c'est un jeu guyane toulouse tu
passes paris masqué on va s'amuser c'est
la comédie c'est la division
c'est l'amusement c'est les pilotes on a
fini on va manger un trop plein de
poissons qui nagent et d'agir
et puis après on chez toi et on repart
le lendemain dans les rues pour faire le
carnage
[Musique]
tout